hey guys my pal I'm de Lisa I'm born and
we just did something pretty crazy the
other night and we want to tell you all
about it so story time can we get some
wine yeah I think it's time to pour some
wine let's get some wine what do you
think the title of the story should be
how about one night and Trump's
childhood home I liked it
clear concise one night and Trump's
child at home cheers Cheers
[Music]
different Queens I am I'm from Queens
and you I just saw your childhood home
is for sale oh wow yeah I want to see
that that's it that's your house that's
where I was born how in the world did
you find out about this okay so this
story goes on buzzfeed.com an article
popped up and it was all about how
trump's childhood home is now an Airbnb
I saw the article and I immediately said
I absolutely want to make a video about
this I think there might be something
wrong with me that we do think that I
would enjoy this well I thought that we
all can share this experience together
it would bring us closer I didn't have
very many expectations into law
but when I got there I was like damn
this is nice
you know this honestly kind of reminds
me of privet drive from Harry Potter oh
[Music]
my god I would say it was a very nice
house especially for the era in which it
was built
I would say that this was a very nice
house it definitely felt very madman all
of the decor in the house is from paint
which was really kind of freaky to me
there's like cardboard cutouts of Trump
and photos of chomp and quotes by them
all over the house everywhere I look
there's something with his face on it
this is my favorite room was the large
room that had so much space for
activities I was doing leaps jetties
this is bigger than my apartment
one bedroom at the back of the house was
the study I could really see like young
Donald crapping in his diaper back there
listen this crap is huge no crap it is
huge like Jerry Seinfeld there's also an
entire shelf and all that's in the Shelf
is like a shrine to Donald Trump and the
Trump working
is weird is as this bedroom is likely
the childhood bedroom of President
Donald J Trump who lived in this home
from 46 to 50 I'm confused as to why
this it says this was likely the bed of
a child like do they not know that it's
a pretty expensive air B&B so yeah like
you're gonna stay here you want to for
sure know which ones know that the
weirdest room was in the master bedroom
with that whack as hell sign that was
hanging above the bed I think I'm in the
master bedroom there looks like there's
something says in this bedroom president
Donald J Trump was likely conceived by
his parents Fred and Mary Trump the
world has never been the same
I just don't understand why it muted to
be said I think we all could have
inferred or gathered the fact that there
was a gold plaque that was a little
lunch this is the room where it happened
and by it I mean I never wanted to think
about that perception but here I am
there were the article copies in every
single room of that house literally this
is in absolutely every room like they
were not kidding when they said that
every bathroom was bright pepto-bismol
pink and then that one large ass tub you
did not like that tub so when it was
time to go to bed how are we all feeling
y'all I feel weird I might need to go
check into like a lucky 2n or something
this is getting creepy regardless of who
lived there before it was just an old
home and it was very quiet and it was
just creepy and eerie I was
uncomfortable so I'm making Hal come
downstairs with me to get the Wi-Fi
password because I'm too scared to do it
by myself was conceived so I just went
to the restroom and myself I'm like look
he knows to just like walk back to the
bedroom
yeah so three o'clock in the morning and
I'm absolutely terrified
protip always go to the restroom before
you go to bed
[Music]
julissa how are you feeling hard to
sleep not gonna lie by Trump how's my
Trump's parents room my trips room okay
the car is coming in four minutes in
Firefox
politics aside I think that being there
in this home with this public figure you
know so well and you knew that this was
his beginning that was his inception and
his conception all deceptions happened
in that damn house I'm glad I went
through that with y'all I don't think it
would have been as fun if it wasn't for
y'all
that is definitely an experience I will
never forget and an experience I never
want to have again
amen to that and finishing this why
[Music]
[Music]